we try to wrap our heads around things
that we don't understand and our
resistance to these outside ideas and
you know how it takes time like now you
know we have
i'm sure you're familiar with wim hof
and all the stuff that he's doing with
breath and
for some reason you know perhaps in part
due to his charisma
um and and the fact that he's sharing so
much on social media
there seems to be a conversation around
breath and this is the autonomic nervous
system
and and you know what i kind of gather
from everything that he does
all of which is rooted in pranayama and
like ancient yogic
breathing techniques is this idea that
we have more control over these systems
that we
we we just believe are are running
automatically within us that we can
actually manipulate that right and
breath
i think is the key to that because it's
the only function you can do completely
consciously or completely unconsciously
and the theory of breath work and
pranayama is that by using your
conscious system to impose
rhythms on the breath you gradually
induce those rhythms in the
involuntary system and that and thereby
you get to the autonomic nervous system
and can change its function
uh that's such a simple idea and it's
something that's been paid so little
attention to
in the west so it's great to see this
coming yeah now he's like being studied
yeah stuff and the cold the cold
exposure is what gets all the attention
but it's really the breath
i think it's really the breath i mean i
think the cold stuff is great i do
i you know have partly as a result of
uh meeting him and and listening to that
you know i i
uh i spend summers in in british
columbia on an island the ocean's pretty
cold there and i go in every day and
yeah
i've gotten to like that night you know
i like cold dips and cold things i think
that's good yeah and that's cold
that's cold yeah but i think as you say
absolutely the breath is the key and
it's it's wonderful suddenly to see
interest in this you know there's books
that have started to come out
uh on breath suddenly being taken
somewhat seriously it was yeah
james nestor's book which is good yeah
what about
these stories that you hear uh about
you know sadhus and caves in the
himalayas who are breatharians and
haven't eaten food for decades well
i was like is this something like have
you ever ever met any of those guys
no i'm an open-minded skeptic
okay so from i'm willing to believe i'm
willing to believe
anything but then i gotta see i want
evidence for it
right you know but but that's different
from being a close-minded skeptic which
is what
you know a lot of people i meet in
medicine or that they from the they they
have a mindset not to believe from the
beginning no i've never met a
breatharian there was one famous guy
uh in los angeles who had a big
following
uh and was caught on videotape stuffing
himself with candy bars in a 7-eleven of
course
yes so i don't know that i haven't seen
however
i've seen enough stuff that make me you
know i'm willing to believe you know
wim hof uh his methods were he got a lot
of that from tibetan
practice and those people that uh you
know
can warm themselves to an incredible
degree and dry
blankets sitting out on a frozen shore
of a frozen lake
i mean sure yeah i've seen that i i've
done
uh fire walking myself and and
very impressed with with that you know
i've i did it the wrong way several
times and then i did it
you know the right way i did one with
tony robbins when he was trying to set a
world record for the longest firework it
was 40 feet over a very hot
bed of coals and and on i had on a
shorter much shorter cooler walk i
burned my feet
but when i did that one i was in the
right state of mind and it was
there was no sensation of heat i walked
slowly i could dig my feet into the hot
coals i had nothing i got really high
you know amazing i mean that was like
and that was totally where my mind was
at the time
yeah and he's taken thousands of people
through that
successfully um so what is the
like how do you explain that well i
think if you're
all right this just guess right and it's
also based on some of my psychedelic
experiences i think if the mind gets out
of the way
it can leave the nervous system
free to allow the body to interact with
external things in ways that
it's very precise and balanced for
example
i one of the experience i i have had
repeatedly
is in a psychedelic state walking
barefoot over sharp stones
which i normally couldn't do because it
hurt too much
but not only did it not hurt there were
no dents in my foot
so that's the interesting aspect you
know what's going on there and it feels
to me as if
if my mind is not interfering that the
muscles
on the surface of the foot can push back
very precisely
to neutralize the force at the surface
of the skin
and that's like some ability that we
have which we normally don't see because
our our mind is somehow not letting that
happen
yeah you have this other story about
about doing yoga and
and being unable to do reverse crow or
whatever it was and
then you know dropping acid or suicide
yeah and then suddenly it was being able
to do it
right but then when it wore off i
couldn't do it again and but but having
seen that i could do it i was motivated
to
practice until i was able right it's a
it's getting the mind out of that
or quieting my mind yeah right and
and then it becomes a conversation
around how do you do that
without exogenous substances well i
think obviously it's possible
uh you know with uh tony robbins
and that firewalk i wasn't taking
anything it was the group
energy that he created that caused the
change
[Music]
you